we are joined by chael anthony and chris
three amazing students who helped create
the magazine pass the spatula
which celebrates chefs of color it is
fantastic
and their cookbook club pick for today
is
quest love's potluck
and here to make a recipe from the book
is james beard award-winning chef author
and executive producer of food and wine
magazine oh my god someone i'm so
excited
kwami on watching
[Applause]
i've just been one of your biggest fans
for so long i don't want to your biggest
fans probably longer
probably longer seriously i've like
never missed a frame of top chef and i'm
so excited that you are a
judge well it's going down this season
all right
portland's a great city it's a great
city and it meant so much for the city
especially right now right we're going
through tough times
to bring some life to the city show the
amazing culinary space
and celebrate diversity within top chef
like you know i think that was a really
really important thing
i am so excited because potluck is
really at the heart of what i wanted
cookbook club to be about which is
let's make something together now hot
luck
is like that is a diverse way to eat
food and it makes people comfortable
because then they can cook what really
speaks to them and they're confident
about or just want to try yeah and they
can bring their own culture to the table
you know so this book it has so much
diversity so much flavor so much
personality that that's what potluck
parties are about right it's about
getting together and showing that
okay so what are we making today kwame
from mixtape potluck
so for the mixtape potluck i can't have
a dish without rice
you know my family's from nigeria
they're from
uh louisiana which is like you know the
rice capital of america
uh they're from the caribbean so we
always have rice at our potlucks when we
get together
and you'll see anything from rice and
peas to jambalaya to jollof rice
and you know you can't talk about
american cuisine without talking about
west african cuisine
really inspired it so jambalaya is a
derivative
from jollof rice so we're going to get
to the source today we're also going to
make a little jerk lamb because i know
you like lamb
so i think i love church well then
you'll love me
and then doing a little gooseberry salad
to brighten it up a little bit
i love gooseberries too yeah they're so
bright and beautiful
and unique i'm glad we're bringing it to
the party today you know what i love i
love this blender
oh i mean that's what i love i can tell
it's got a little style on
it thank you i'm excited to hear your
thoughts on its performance because at
the end of the day it can't just look
pretty it has
so let's get into it let's perform okay
and we're making a red stew so this is
like a mother sauce
of um of west african cuisine
so we're going to add some peppers some
garlic some ginger
a little bit of curry powder i'm going
to add the scotch bonnet sauce
hey guys how are you doing chime in this
is your
platform too the smell
you guys in the studio is just
it's aromatic it's permeating it's so
beautiful all right here we go
kwami i'm excited to see what you think
this is user-friendly if
ever
i just want it to work that looks like
it worked to me
that looked like it worked to me so
that's it
then you hit off i was going to ask
chael if you had any questions since
we're making a sauce
that has some curry powder and i know
you like a curry
i do so maybe for someone who doesn't
like a lot of spice i know some curry
powders do have a little bit of spice
um what would you say is kind of like an
alternate
alternative for like curry powder
luckily for this sauce it's such a small
amount of curry powder
and this curry powder doesn't have any
heat it's more spice forward so it's a
lot of flavor
but like i said it's such a small amount
of curry powder that you're not really
going to
taste the curry essentially chael and
anthony and chris
i wish you could smell this sauce i
can't put it down it's like my new
favorite culinary perfume
it is unbelievable
it's extraordinary kwame it's so
aromatic and then when it cooks down
you know you cook it in a little bit of
oil we've already added to the pot you
know skip some steps but
the dehydrates so a lot of the water
comes out of this
the aromatics cook it gets so much more
intensely flavored
and that's when we're able to add it to
our toasted rice here
and make our signature deluxe rice oh
yeah it's hot right
we have a question about tomatoes
and then i'm gonna add my water yeah uh
what's the best variety of tomatoes to
use in this recipe
okay that is such a good question you
know i like to use plum tomatoes
they're a little bit more consistent um
but whatever's in season you know i say
that's that's always my answer
whatever's in season is the best thing
to use
so i want to talk about this lamb for a
second now you see all these ingredients
here
all of this right here you got the green
onion your ginger your garlic your
scotch bonnet
we have some allspice we have some clove
we have some cinnamon
um some tamarind thyme
it's beautiful and then you blitz all
that up and when you marinate the lamb
it's best to do it at least 24 hours
then we're going to sear the lamb and
then cook it in the oven
until your desired temperature i'm
salivating
but i'm looking at the dishes and i it's
dripping
will you show me how to plate this i got
it because i need to take a bite
so we have the jaloff rice already so
i'm gonna just plate this on here
do you have a tray i i don't but i'm
happy to just
go like this also like that totally by
the way
do it
oh my god oh he's got a little zing
got a little zing a little spicy doing a
little dancing
that's called the jollof rice shimmy oh
you're doing it it comes naturally
it comes naturally no matter what you do
when you bite it you do that
i could have stopped that's incredible
these gooseberries have just been
marinating a little bit
anthony i'm chris and chaya will you
please
join the party with us and partake i
want to see some dancing on that side
too
absolutely um i have to say
this is some of the best rice i've ever
had in my entire life
call me i am blown away that
really means a lot to me and it means a
lot for my culture you know and for me
to share it with you
and for you to love it um really makes
my heart smile
so thank you um chael anthony
here look let me show you how to do it
you got to do it like this you got to
you got to let the shoulders go
we need to play some afro beats because
it just looks like we're like shoeing
someone away without some music right
now
well i just want to tell you i've been
such a fan of yours for a really long
time
and i would love to do this with you
again i'm so happy for you
and your amazing career and all the
incredible collaborations whether it's
with
the mixtape potluck cookbook or with the
past the spatula family
and top chef food and wine my goodness
kwame the list is endless thank you
i really appreciate you thank you for
having me here um
this means the world to me and i'm glad
you like the rice i'm glad you like the
rice
okay is that okay then i could pick it
up thank you chef kwame
cha anthony and chris i love your
magazine i have had it on my desk
for months on end and i dreamt of
getting to collaborate with you on the
show
because i love what you're doing and um
be sure to watch chef kwame on top chef
thursdays at 8 7 central on bravo
and then head to the passthespatula.com
for more information
and to purchase a copy of the magazine
and don't forget to pick up a copy
of quest love's mixtape potluck
to add to your cookbook collection it's
really
one of a kind and from from from my
opinion as a cookbook lover
it's kind of the one we've been waiting
for so thank you so much
you